with great power comes another trailer
so the latest trailer for spider-man
homecoming has hit and I am really been
looking for something to be a bit more
positive about because I don't assume
you guys are sick of me being negative
about everything I'm kind of think of
being negative about everything
unfortunately I do have issues with I've
actually got one really big one but you
know what that's coming at the end let's
start positive because you know what
almost everything I saw I liked or if I
didn't flat out like it it didn't annoy
me so there's a lot to enjoy here I like
to record the Tom Holland has with
Robert Downey jr. as Peter and Tony i
love that Tony tossed off the line you
know friendly neighborhood spider-man
but like not just to crowbar it in but
it's like no this is the scale you
should be working on your the
neighborhood hero let the Avengers worry
about the huge stuff I like that sort of
finding a way to use that classic
descriptor of spider-man but sort of
have a narrative justification for it i
like that i really like the rapport and
the vibe of the back and forth between
him and his friend i love with any less
his friend trying to suit on i think the
way the suit kind of sucks in that's
really cool because it kind of helps
answer the question how to get in that
thing so quickly well it just sort of
slipped sit on and then it fits itself
cool that's nifty I am really intrigued
by Michael Keaton's vulture I'm just
liking the vibe off him I like to see
seems to have some anger builds up
against the wealthy that might feed into
his backstory the whole I'll do anything
for my family line felt weird and out of
nowhere I it's might guess just based on
focusing that my family he means like
his crew um you know that he does hikes
with or whatever I don't really know
that why I felt a little out of place
but I just the general vibe of dangerous
and like the vibe he gives off his that
he's got nothing against spider-man but
if the guys in his way he's going to
kill him and I kind of I kinda like that
because I mean we've seen so many
personal vendettas against spider-man
pretty much every movie so to have
someone who's got their own goal and
spider-mans just in the way that's
that's a nice changeup from characters
like the green goblin or venom or
electro and these characters who were
really out to get him so it's a nice
break from that I like the sense of
escalation where Peters like on the
ferry nice clip in and he doing the web
and he's like I got this and then the
vulture just tears through your whole
thing like no no I do not have this I
really like Tony's lines with him when
he's when he's telling him you know
don't be like me you're supposed to be
better and if you need the suit that you
shouldn't have it I mean coming from
Tony these are perfect lives because
he's obviously channeling so much of
what he wishes he was better and he's
he's projecting his own failings in a
way onto Peter and he wants Peter to to
be better and when he sees Peter making
nice the not the same mistakes with
doing things that remind him of the
things that he himself that Tony has
done that he knows weren't for the best
he kind of takes out in him and I'd like
that because it means Tony isn't just
there to as a cameo to be a father
figure the tony is there with his own
stuff going on his own baggage going on
that's getting in dollars I like fast so
like I said this pretty much everything
that I see in this trailer I like the
problem is that a lot of memory I kind
of wish I hadn't seen and I feel like in
a way I oh I don't want to say i don't
want apology but I owe a minor addendum
to my thoughts on when i did my review
of the Justice League trailer because
there was something i should have
acknowledged but so many other things
that annoy me that it didn't occur to me
to the one thing there were girls of
your feelings about the Justice League
trailer about what it represents them
what you think the movies going to be it
didn't give away a ton of plot and that
was good especially given how much clock
are completely given away in the
marketing and the trailers in BBS ahead
of that release so that is something
that deserves acknowledgement that
occurred to me watching this trailer
which is full of stuff I am really
liking but I can't let it off the hook
for something i raked BBS over the coals
for which is showing so much of the plot
now
strictly speaking we don't know really
how far into the movie these this stuff
goes but it feels like we could possibly
beginning right up to the final
confrontation because I mean if Peters
last sort of big thing with the vulture
is when he doesn't have the suit after
Tony taken away from him then we saw
that now it's possible that's just the
action capper because if we go by say
Civil War we saw pretty with everything
leading up to that big apt to climax at
the airport with just a few glimpses of
what came after that and that was sort
of where the film was able to go the
extra mile and give us some stuff that
maybe we weren't expecting with where it
went there so if this confrontation of
Peter in his old home made suit
confronting the vulture is saved the
climax back to and we've still got all
the bacteria they haven't shown us that
then that's fine unfortunately I don't
know / sir that's the case and and even
if that is the case i still can't
completely let this trailer off the hook
because it does lay out the plot so
specifically so now i know that
regardless of whether it was the ferry
or not that there's something that
teener does that make sony take away the
suit i would have preferred to have been
surprised by that turn of events in the
theater I now I now know how how the
whole thing with the ferry gets resolved
that's a big one in my book that was a
big annoys because it was a great capper
on the original teaser like him trying
to oldest ferry together and me seeing
that going how in the heck is he gonna
deal with this I mean is he just kind of
fail how would he possibly succeed well
now I know Tony comes in and saves it so
any tension that that really great image
had is now gone and I don't like that so
I wish I could be more positive on the
show but again everything I saw I liked
I guess wished I hadn't shown me so much
and and with what they did show me I
mean hopefully there's still some
surprises in store but even if they are
the stuff that they showed me they broke
down it felt like they broke down the
entire layout for whatever sections of
the film they didn't show me and now I
know more about what to expect out of
stories going in then I would like to
have known I mean that bait basically
like 30 minutes after ice on the trailer
my friend Ryan who is occasionally on
the show he sent me
message saying if you don't want to be
spoiled for any of the plot don't watch
the new spider-man trailer on my dude I
wish you had told me this like 45
minutes ago because if I if I had known
how much stuff was gone and I suppose as
possible and kind of known but i mean
when i use I make a point of not
watching other people's reactions before
I throw my own because I want my own to
be my own feeling my own thoughts so I
yeah I just wish I'd known how much of
the plot within this thing because it's
all good I just how I preferred to have
been surprised by it in the theater but
that's sort of where I land on this
trailer it's a mixed bag of emotions
because I like it all but I wish I was
going to be surprised in the theater so
I don't know what are you going to do
what were your thoughts on the new
spider-man homecoming trailer whatever
they were drop something down to comment
and let's talk about it don't forget to
Like subscribe check me out on Twitter
at council of geeks give a listen to the
council beat podcast available on iTunes
and stitcher and until next time this
council is adjourned
[Applause]